[Aplausos]
[Música]
india es el país que más películas
produce en todo el mundo pero eso ya lo
sabéis todo el mundo ha oído hablar de
la industria de cine de bollywood verdad
pero os voy a hacer una pregunta cuál es
el segundo país productor de cine cuál
iría en la lista después de bollywood
[Música]
la respuesta es nigeria seguro que
ninguno lo habéis adivinado pero mis
queridos amigos de visual polític
hollywood produce muchos más títulos al
año que el mismísimo hollywood y casi
nadie lo sabe porque seamos honestos
áfrica es el continente olvidado la
política de la economía africana a duras
penas salen en los medios y por eso
podemos decir que los africanos están
viviendo un milagro silencioso durante
los últimos 40 años del siglo 20 esta
región apenas era capaz de crecer pero
de repente boom en el año 2002 empieza a
subir como la espuma
[Música]
un poco más de 15 años los africanos han
triplicado sus ingresos algunos países
como etiopía están creciendo a ritmos
del 10% interanual y ya sé lo que estáis
pensando muchos a ver fonseca que sí que
vale que la gráfica está muy bien pero
realmente está mejorando la vida de los
africanos vamos a ver que nadie se
espere ver ni rascacielos ni centros
comerciales en cada esquina ni muchísimo
menos una clase media pujante todavía no
estamos ahí es más aún quedan regiones y
países enteros que no han mejorado por
ejemplo la república democrática del
congo o la república centroafricana
siguen totalmente hundidos en la pobreza
extrema
[Música]
pero hay muchas otras partes que están
mejorando por ejemplo en addis abeba la
capital de etiopía están empezando a
abrir supermercados esto nos puede
parecer la cosa más normal del mundo es
un paso de gigante si tenemos en cuenta
que hace 30 años todo el país estaba
sumido en una de las mayores hambrunas
de la historia pero no sólo eso ya
empezamos a ver empresas africanas que
se están expandiendo internacionalmente
ahí tenemos el ejemplo de empresa que es
un método de pago o etiopía en airlines
[Música]
y os preguntaréis porque áfrica está
creciendo que ha cambiado en el
continente y la respuesta es muy
sencilla paz veréis el primer requisito
para que un país se desarrolle es que no
tenga guerras después viene todo lo
demás pero ninguna sociedad puede
desarrollarse si viven en un campo de
batalla continuo y esa ha sido la
situación de áfrica durante décadas
guerras de independencia conflictos
tribales e incluso genocidios
sin embargo hoy en día la mayor parte de
estos conflictos han terminado para que
os hagáis una idea en 1990 una media de
45 africanos por cada 100.000 morían por
razones bélicas hoy esa cifra ha caído a
8 por cada 100.000 y todo esto ha
ayudado a impulsar el comercio la
inversión extranjera sobre todo por
parte de china sin embargo y como
decíamos antes todavía queda muchísimo
trabajo por hacer
áfrica no es ni de lejos una región
próspera que da el siguiente paso para
desarrollarse y cuál es ese siguiente
paso
exacto tener industria
[Música]
por el momento áfrica sigue siendo un
continente rural salvo honrosas
excepciones- todo lo que nos llega de
esta zona del mundo son materias primas
y así es bastante difícil que una región
pueda prosperar pues bien en este
contexto es en el que ha ocurrido esta
noticia
[Música]
el mayor acuerdo de libre comercio en
casi un cuarto de siglo busca hacer de
áfrica un mercado único habéis oído bien
el objetivo es crear una versión
africana de lo que en su día fue el
mercado único europeo que es el germen
de lo que hoy conocemos como la unión
europea
[Música]
pues bien desde el 30 de mayo de 2019
este área de libre comercio es una
realidad hablamos de nada menos que 52
países tan solo benin eritrea y nigeria
han rechazado formar parte del llamado
ft
vale vale tenemos que hacer una
actualización tan sólo unos días después
de que terminaremos de grabar este vídeo
benin y nigeria firmaron el tratado pero
la pregunta es de verdad este acuerdo
puede cambiar las cosas o son sólo
palabras bonitas de verdad un acuerdo de
libre comercio puede mejorar la vida de
los africanos hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
sin mercado no hay industria
cuando hablamos de áfrica tenemos que
recordar una cosa áfrica tiene 55 países
1300 millones de personas es imposible
hablar de todo un continente y como si
fuera un único país pero aún así hay
algo que casi todas las naciones
africanas han tenido en común y casi
todas fueron colonias de países europeos
a duras penas llevan 50 años siendo
naciones independientes pero seamos
honestos todavía mantienen unos lazos
con sus antiguas metrópolis y esa
independencia de la que hablamos en
muchos casos es más una ilusión que otra
cosa veréis normalmente el principal
socio comercial de un país son sus
vecinos los españoles comerciamos con
los franceses
los franceses comercia con los alemanes
los alemanes comercia con los holandeses
eeuu comercia con méxico pero con quien
comercian los países africanos pues la
verdad es que comercian con cualquiera
menos con quien tienen al lado por
ejemplo costa de márfil costa de marfil
está al lado de cania y de liberia sin
embargo a duras
penas comercian con estos países su
principal socio comercial es países
bajos y francia qué sorpresa es su
antiguo colonizador no obstante esta
tendencia está empezando a cambiar
aunque no en la dirección que os
podríais imaginar si seguís visual
política desde hace tiempo ya sabéis que
la presencia china en áfrica se ha
multiplicado de forma espectacular y ojo
porque no son los únicos asiáticos
atentos a esta noticia
la desaceleración de china abre las
puertas a la expansión del comercio
africano con la india tal cual como lo
es en los últimos 15 años el comercio de
áfrica también se ha triplicado con
países como turquía o indonesia
es decir que asia ya supone un 45% del
comercio exterior de los países
africanos mientras tanto el comercio con
europa representa a un 30% y esto
significa que apenas queda un porcentaje
para el comercio inter africano los
africanos a duras penas se relacionan
entre ellos y ya se lo que estaréis
pensando y que donde está el problema
cada uno comercia con quien quiere o con
quién puede no se supone que hay
globalización pues sí pero a la vez no
pensadlo bien si creéis que es lo que
envían principalmente los países
africanos a asia y europa
[Música]
pues todo lo que os estáis imaginando
materias primas como el petróleo y el
gas el oro el uranio en otras palabras
todo menos productos industriales y todo
esto tiene una explicación por ejemplo
en el año 2017
unos ruandeses crearon una empresa la
ruanda motorcycle company y esta empresa
como su propio nombre indica fabrica
motos low cost
como os podéis imaginar ninguna de estas
motos podría competir en calidad con una
suzuki o una honda es decir que alguien
de un país europeo o asiático nunca
compraría una moto de ruanda pudiendo
comprar una que venga de japón o de
alemania así que siguiendo con el
ejemplo donde pueden vender sus motos
los ruandeses pues está claro en otros
países africanos de hecho podrían
venderse francamente bien porque apenas
tendrían competidores no olvidéis una
cosa casi ninguna marca internacional se
molesta en vender en áfrica es decir que
si por algún casual de la vida vivís en
el congo y queréis comprar una bmw lo
más probable es que ni siquiera
encontréis un concesionario donde os la
venda
esto significa que en principio nuestros
amigos de la rue andan motors hay que el
company tendría en un mercado entero por
explotar sin competidores
todo esto explica que aunque los
africanos comercian poco entre ellos la
mayor parte del comercio inter africano
no son materias primas sino manufacturas
en otras palabras que si los africanos
quieren tener más fábricas necesitarán
poder comerciar más entre ellos el
problema quién áfrica las cosas nunca
son fáciles y el comercio tampoco lo es
siempre ha tenido que hacer frente a
varios problemas las fronteras en áfrica
son sinónimos de aranceles burocracia y
corrupción si tú quieres enviar tu moto
ruandesa hasta el congo vas a tener que
pagar aranceles de hasta el 20% pero
además tendrás que sobornar al guardia
de la frontera para que no tengas la
mercancía para dar durante meses como os
podéis imaginar para cualquier empresa
es muy difícil ampliar mercados en estas
funciones es más si tenemos en cuenta
que hasta hace cuatro días todos estos
países se mataban entre sí
la cuestión es aún más complicada y de
nuevo una fábrica de motos en ruanda no
puede sobrevivir con un mercado tan
pequeño y sobre todo tan pobre como el
ruandés
y ampliar el alcance de sus ventas tanto
como le sea posible si no es cuestión de
tiempo que he hecho en el cierre y lo
mismo pasa con cualquier otra industria
que os podáis imaginar si no puedes
vender tus productos ni siquiera te vas
a molestar en montar la empresa en otras
palabras que el proteccionismo está
haciendo imposible que áfrica pueda
salir del todo de la pobreza sin embargo
atentos porque todo esto puede cambiar
[Música]
entre mercosur y mercado común diamante
de sangre es una película de hollywood
que nos cuenta con toda la crudeza
posible cómo podemos llegar a matarnos
por unos pocos pedruscos la conclusión
de la historia es que lo único que le
interesa a occidente en áfrica son sus
materias primas ante esta situación
muchos pensarían que los africanos no
saben hacer las cosas por sí mismos y
necesitan un occidental benevolente que
vaya a ayudarles pero esto es visual
político y ya sabéis que aquí pensamos
de otra manera
en la historia de áfrica ha sido escrita
por otros necesitamos ser dueños de
nuestros problemas y soluciones y
escribir nuestra historia paul kagamé
walk a game es el presidente de ruanda
en este vídeo ya os contábamos que es un
político con luces y sombras su modelo a
seguir es singapur así que desde el
punto de vista de la democracia y los
derechos humanos que haga me deja mucho
que desear ahora bien en materia
económica se ha convertido en un
auténtico modelo a seguir pero es que
además de presidir ruanda kagamé también
preside en la unión africana esta
organización nació en el año 2001 y está
clarísimamente inspirada en la unión
europea su gran objetivo es convertir a
áfrica en un mercado común al igual que
lo es
europa y por el momento parece que lo
están consiguiendo
la zona de libre mercado africana entre
en vigor con la ratificación de gambia
exacto hablamos del llamado cft y el
objetivo final es llegar a tener una
moneda única para todo el continente
algo así como el euro pero en versión
africana habrá que esperar todavía 15 o
20 años pero esta es la meta que se ha
marcado la unión africana
[Aplausos]
ahora bien he esperado un momento porque
no todo es tan bonito veréis existen
acuerdos de libre comercio y acuerdos de
libre comercio por ejemplo tenemos el
caso del mercosur mercosur también nació
para crear una área de libre comercio en
latinoamérica y os preguntaréis ha
funcionado pues no los países que lo
firmaron no estaban dispuestos a ceder
soberanía ninguno quería quitar los
aranceles y permitir que sus empresas
nacionales compitieran con las
extranjeras es decir que mercosur tiene
cientos de excepciones si son palabras
muy bonitas pero a la hora de la verdad
el comercio entre los países que lo
firmaron apenas ha crecido y algo
parecido podría ocurrir con esta
supuesta área de libre comercio africana
las dos principales economías de áfrica
sudáfrica y nigeria ven con muchísimo
recelo a este tratado
sudáfrica ha afirmado a última hora pero
nigeria se los sigue per y como os decía
antes
nigeria ha firmado unos días después de
que hiciéramos este vídeo
no penséis que los nigerianos han
recibido este tratado con los brazos
abiertos todavía siguen muy recelosos de
comerciar con sus vecinos y si no me
creéis mirad lo que decía su presidente
[Música]
[Aplausos]
7a no permitiré que nigeria se convierta
en un vertedero
mohamud bujari presidente de nigeria
básicamente en los gobiernos no quieren
perder el control de la poquita
industria que tienen tampoco quieren
perder los ingresos que recaudan por los
aranceles pensando bien en un país como
nigeria donde apenas hay una economía
bien estructurada es casi imposible
recaudar impuestos a la renta por
ejemplo así que casi todos los ingresos
del gobierno vienen de lo único que
realmente controlan el comercio exterior
pero hay más cosas
[Música]
lo cierto es que este tratado este ft ha
generado tantas dudas como esperanzas
veréis normalmente un tratado así se
negocia durante un montón de años y el
cft ha se ha logrado en apenas cuatro
han intentado abarcar tantísimos estados
de golpe que han dejado muchos asuntos
fuera de la mesa el documento final es
una cosa muy genérica con buenas
palabras pero pocos detalles falta
explicar cómo regular los temas de
competencia de inversión y de derechos
de propiedad intelectual y todavía no
hay ni siquiera una lista de productos
liberalizados o una lista con los
productos que se quieren proteger
[Música]
en principio el compromiso es quitar
aranceles a un 90 por ciento de los
productos en la próxima década pero
claro si los gobiernos optan por dejar
dentro de ese 10% con aranceles todas
las mercancías que realmente importan
pues qué queréis que os diga poco
comercio libre vamos a tener aquí pero
esperad un momento porque todavía hay
más problemas
efectivamente el cft ha sería fantástico
para que áfrica pudiera crear sus
propias fábricas si esto es cierto pero
por el momento áfrica es un continente
agrícola y qué pasa con todos esos
millones de agricultores africanos pues
como os podéis imaginar no están
precisamente contentos los
contrabandistas prosperan mientras que
nigeria trata de mantener alejado el
arroz extranjero en este caso nigeria
tiene miedo de venir es su país vecino
benin se ha convertido en un gran
importador de arroz tailandés por lo
visto el arroz tailandés tiene muy buena
calidad y muy buenos precios y de
repente nigeria
abriera sus fronteras sus productores de
arroz lo podrían pasar muy pero que muy
mal y ahí es donde llega el gran dilema
para muchos gobiernos africanos
arriesgamos nuestro sector agrícola a
cambio de crear nuevas industrias en el
futuro o nos quedamos como estamos y así
es como llegamos al tema central de esta
historia según naciones unidas si el cft
se aplicara tal y como quiere la unión
africana el comercio interamericano
crecería en un 52% para el año 2022 es
decir sólo tres años después del momento
en el que hacemos este vídeo ahora bien
si los países miembros mantienen sus
recelos podemos terminar con un tratado
fallido es decir que nuestros amigos de
las motos ruandesas seguirían sin poder
abrir mercados y si no hay mercado no
hay industria
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros creéis que el cp te conseguirá
ser un tratado al estilo de la unión
europea o terminará siendo un tratado al
estilo mercosur llegaremos a ver una
industria que saque al continente
africano de la pobreza
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios mientras tanto no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]